è una persona particolare non sono
spiegarti cosa ha tante sfaccettature 60
poliedrico l'ho letta l'altro giorno per
sbaglio del dizionario accordi tra
virtuale cioè aspetta se guardi bene c'è
un brufolo non so se la pelle d'oca non
sai come si dice in inglese
goss bumps e ciuccio vediamo se sei
questa pacific è bravo però oggi sono
tipo quello di matrix già perso ciao
ragazzi siamo io e giampiero oggi su
gang bis bravo
ricordarsi dei lost bumps che prima
mente è un gioco che si fa in due che
conoscete frase tutti in realtà solo lui
non lo conosce sa glielo faccio vedere
in realtà non l'ho mai giocato allora
non sa se poi puoi giocare in a2 online
non puoi giocare il cice locale però
magari poter giocare sempre in due
anche online oddio league sto male
vai live tour il più ricco da letto dove
senti schiaccia qualche ti aspetta
ok questo tipo è bello basile questo
bimbo malato forse sono personaggi reali
qualcosa donald trump dove sembrava dai
lato col toro sulla rapina va bene piace
ti piace il toro invece non sa che il
file del tuo cognome
questa è piaciuto non è vero ci sono
tantissime santoro mi sa di sì se i
tesserini calling bank sa bene corpo a
corpo
in questo gioco i nomi di chi non mi
ricordo di volta che l'ho giocato è
passato un sacco di tempo per tutti
visto che devi spingere signora feeling
non lo so anche combatti tu devi buttare
in un altro rapido a ficcare dei
cazzotti tipo questi stavano salendo
tranquilli dell'ascensore cavalca sono
scemo poco smetta voglio commettere il
suicidio non puoi far sì che anche male
ci siamo o no ma con una cosa ma che
schifo di ragazzi cosa è successo ho
vinto ma con meno troppo forte
stava morendo i tasti non è su vale
vabbè allora questa è la prima seria
perché la prima era va verso la seconda
non esistita mai si va ok vola
no no no no no no no no ma non si tiene
ho pregato li aspetta ho potuto vedere
valentine quella scena anche se lanciato
essere costruiti conferisce così via
fisc io non stia cadendo però mi sono
tirato su a metà no no no adesso che
avuto anch'io però va bene così deve
essere la prima ho vinto io non va bene
ne mancano set scappi diver
e sai perchè non ho più avversari qui
perché perché sono morti posti barca h o
no no no this is not a che informa i
cani come pensi di mannaia lato
no no no no no no no no come si fa ad
alzare l'altro da una donna che è brutta
vai vai dentro aia si sono succede così
non scappa
basta dice non è vero ho vinto io no
notai sono morto morto sono svenuto dai
dai modi tu muori
ma manuela caso conta in un interesse
tagliate ma perché non carne scuse e bay
no no no no no e poi teoricamente sì ti
prego
novara no no no tu no che sì il trenino
che non ho mai visto ne frega bellissimo
aia dai fosse per me finiresti giù con
le corna dei file che paura che fa
voracova favorisca questa cosa no no no
ragazzi difficilissimo 9 si no che
succede
no dai così come fatto esultare prima di
3 a 0 blogger di successo
si no
la sala migliori leve non fosse non
esulto e stato divertente poi trovata di
farle per pareggiare devi farle tutte le
statistiche manco una frase motivo per
tutto dai vieni by nokia che testata
theora ha fatto cio da brothers
trattenendo non so come ma l'importante
è divertirsi ragazzi sicuramente non è
mai vinto nè mai vincere basta che ha
poi ok
si temevano luogo e provati 6 suscitato
però io sono semplicemente fatto un giro
normale mi piace questo gioco
no però ma che c è troppa no non ho mai
a non aver stappato al market è stata
forte
spetta è stata fortissima ma ti sta
impegnando si tantissimo sette su otto
l'ultima dai l'ultimo so che dire beh
non ci ho mai giocato una volta ma tipo
è cambiato tantissimo ma no aspetta che
chi testata casi a mori basta
ma no sono al toro sono un toro dai da
non è ma mi ama caccia allo scatto
dobbiamo farci portare la dan caten
spero non la cava quindi c'è ancora
un'altra chance
no ragazzi e mi sto arrabbiando dalle
bellissime parate v perché adesso ci
serva di monito o no però spero che
questo video sia di stato di vostro
gradimento
noi abbiamo cioè io sono sicuro che c'è
stato in bici ci sia stato impegno non
sono sicuro del risultato però
l'importante ragazzi a giocare con i
nostri amici e farli sentire a casa
vostra
quando gioca tizia da 16 devono essere
contenti di giocare con voi perché è
importante
mi ricordo i tempi come quando giocavo
col mio fratellino piccolo per noi non
ho mai avuto un fratellino piccolo
quindi quest'anno tutto ok voglio essere
confratelli noi e se anche ci sto
pensando prima tipo un'altra a caso non
della ragazzi si va bene non voglio
cambiare schiena aspetta il cambio
schifo anzi aspetti aspetta lops
permette aspetta lo voglio e lo rosa
come è la cacca da carriera da ragazzi
preparatevi per la mia rivincita
sarai vinci tutte e due titolato buono
come sarà messo in the hot
però tengo a prender nota che ci sono
scherzava ma si no la buona ma mannaia
morta si è successo no non è vero sono
le compravano no no non riesco a salire
morì muori basta basta sì non si muore
più
non è così e bellissimo giorno no non
sono più basse fuori moda ma lingua
noi storici devi morire
mamma mia arrivo che vorrà mica volete
veramente difficile ok no no no no
oddio non l'ha mai schiacciato la roma
store esistevano non deve fare per noia
o riso tantissimo ho riso tantissimo
sono dieci su dieci una morte lenta
ragazzi non è possibile dice va almeno
una cioè io ho vinto la prima foto non
sapevo ma neanche adesso che ride no ora
che è stato bellissimo
dobbiamo rifarlo ti prego se vuoi
skillati primapress
e stato veramente se me lo compro non lo
so ma è stato beneficio ragazzi
ringrazio giampiero per l'apatia no
quindi ringrazia giampiero io sì per
aver partecipato questo video 10 mi
piace a testa perché meritano ragazzi
spero vi sia piaciuto
lascio canale di giampiero in
descrizione lasciato in un live così si
ripigliano attimo che io riguarda lo
stolido a vita quando sono triste è
stato bellissimo casa i ragazzi mi fa
piacere tutto mi piace così sto cercando
da letizia le cose come si discute non
ci vediamo hanno preso vita
varazze
[Musica]